-Polls continue to show that
Americans overwhelmingly support
the Black Lives Matter protests
against police brutality
and systemic racism,
and that's why the President
and the police are lashing out.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
We're living through a moment
of national crisis
unprecedented in our lifetimes.
The nation
is convulsing with outrage
over the brutal murder
of George Floyd,
local police
and federal law enforcement
have responded to
peaceful protests with violence,
there are secret police
with no name badges or insignia
lined up in the nation's capital
like extras from a [bleep]
Steven Seagal movie --
not one of the high-enders.
One of the...
A highly infectious virus
which has killed
over 110,000 Americans
hasn't gone anywhere.
I mean, we're learning more
about COVID-19 every day,
but I doubt we'll ever find out
it's prone
to politely excuse itself.
"Hey, we didn't realize
the extent of this
whole racism thing
you have going on,
so we're just gonna...
We're just gonna go."
Unemployment is at
its highest level
since the Great Depression.
If this was the first chapter
of a YA novel,
the teen protagonist would say
"screw it" and move to Canada.
And through it all,
the President is a recluse
cowering in a bunker
behind an 8-foot-tall fence
like JD Scowlinger.
[Salinger]
Next time he appears in public,
he's going to have
10-inch fingernails
and a Unabomber beard.
Of course, his beard
would probably look like this.
Yeah, it's a hair joke. Sue me.
Just think of it as a way of
taking a breath of clean air
before diving back
into [Bleep] River.
This is a moment of
national anguish, heartache,
and suffering unlike any
we've seen in recent memory.
Or, as the President
put it on Friday...
-Today is probably,
if you think of it,
the greatest comeback
in American history.
But you --
It's not going to stop here.
It's going to keep going.
-Jesus.
I haven't heard anything that
tone-deaf since Rob Gronkowski
appeared on "The Masked Singer."
I mean, I'm still --
I'm still pretty impressed
they found a mascot head
big enough
to fit over his actual head.
I always assumed Rob Gronkowski
was a "Masked Singer" costume
with a singer inside him,
that one of the greatest
tight ends of all time
was actually Patti LaBelle
in a Gronkowski suit.
But this isn't a comeback yet.
It's not a comeback at all.
When the Knicks are losing by 30
and hit a 3-pointer
at the buzzer to lose by 27,
the deejay doesn't play
"Y'all Ready For This?"
There's no question
the May jobs report was good
and better than expected.
And also a little misleading.
I mean, a lot of the jobs that
were supposedly created are jobs
that were lost to the pandemic
being re-created.
It's like bragging
that you lost 3 pounds
right after you gained
45 pounds.
But to suggest
that we're not mired
in an unprecedented calamity
is just deranged.
Nearly 40% of households with
incomes of less than $40,000
have reported job losses.
Meanwhile, U.S. billionaires
have become $565 billion richer
since March 18th.
That's right --
billionaires actually
got richer during the pandemic,
while the poorest households
lost jobs.
We're living in a dystopian film
written and directed
by Bernie Sanders.
"See it, don't see it,
who cares?
But one thing we all agree on --
$6 for popcorn is insane!"
I miss him being around because
I think it became a passable --
a passable impression.
But, of course,
Trump is celebrating because
things really have been just
fine for his wealthy patrons
and the corporate husks
he chums around with
at the Mar-a-Lago omelette bar,
which, knowing Trump,
is probably BYO eggs.
"We provide the peppers.
The pepper? We just have
the one pepper, but don't worry.
It's a good pepper.
It's like a red or a green.
It's -- It's a yellow?
We have one yellow pepper
for everyone at
the omelette station to share."
And while millions of Americans
have been in the streets
protesting systemic racism
and police brutality
only to be met with
more brutality from the police
and a pandemic that has killed
110,000 Americans
and unemployment
is at the highest point
since the Great Depression,
Trump is still bragging
about the stock market.
-Our stock market is almost --
It's just short
of an all-time high.
I've had 144 all-time-high
stock markets
during a three-and-a-half-year
period.
Nobody's ever
come close to that.
And we're going to do it again.
But it's going to be
even stronger than last time.
When I would say that to you
two, three months ago,
I could see what's happen --
I have a good f--
I've always done well
with numbers.
-No, you haven't always
done well with numbers.
I mean,
just ask these two zeros.
No one who is actually good
with numbers ever has to say,
"I've always done well
with numbers."
If your doctor took your
blood pressure and then said,
"I've always done well
with numbers,"
you might want to get
a second opinion.
"Yeah, my last doctor
said my blood pressure
was, uh...
negative-52 degrees Celsius.
Is that -- Is that bad?"
But the more shocking thing
is Trump bragging
about the stock market.
If 40 million people
have filed for unemployment
and over 100,000 have died
and police are violently beating
peaceful protesters,
maybe the stock market
hitting an all-time high
doesn't actually mean
we as a country
are at an all-time high.
We used to hear that the stock
market hates uncertainty,
and I don't know
what clearer sign of uncertainty
there could possibly be
than unemployed Americans
putting on industrial masks
and stepping over
empty tear-gas containers
on their way to cash
a $1,200 government check.
Maybe -- Maybe this is your hint
that the stock market
is actually bull [bleep].
Kind of like when you're a kid
and you find the Christmas
presents in the closet,
and your first thought is,
"That's weird.
Why would Santa store
his presents in our closet?"
Then your mom signs a permission
slip for a field trip,
and you think, "That is weird.
Why does Santa
have the same handwriting
as my mom?"
And then you come downstairs
early on Christmas
and see your dad on the floor
using all the curse words
as he tries to tie a bow
around a Hatchimal,
and you finally realize,
"Oh, Mom and Dad work for Santa,
and I'm Santa's baby."
Trump and his allies
have been gleefully celebrating
one good jobs report amid
an ongoing national calamity
to the point where
you can't help but conclude
that they are totally detached
from reality.
Watch this very real clip
the White House posted
over the weekend
from Trump's top economic
advisor, Larry Kudlow.
-America is coming back.
Three million new jobs,
lower unemployment rate,
furloughed temporary layoffs
going back to work.
Green shoots
popping up everywhere.
Stocks are soaring.
POTUS policies are working.
Stay with the winners!
Trump and Pence and me!
The best is yet to come!
-Are you about to
sell me a mattress?
Are you telling me to
"come on down to America"?
I feel like I'm watching
a local commercial
for Crazy Larry Kudlow's
Discount Furniture Warehouse.
"Come on down to Larry
Discount Furniture Warehouse!
Our quality is Kud-high,
but our prices are Kud-low!"
"You want another take, Larry?"
"No, yeah, we got it!"
Of course, Trump and his buddies
are gleefully celebrating
the soaring stock market.
Our deeply unjust system
works for them just fine,
inflating the wealth of the most
privileged people in our society
even in a time
of abject misery and crisis
while crushing
the poor and working class.
It's rigged to protect
the privileged and the powerful,
and the same
is true of policing.
Last week, you might remember
Trump had this to say
when he gave a speech
threatening to unleash
America's military
against American citizens.
-One law and order.
And that is what it is.
One law.
We have one beautiful law.
-Okay, first of all,
I don't know why you need
to be creepy toward "the law."
"Beautiful law"
sounds like a show on USA
about a group of swimsuit models
who become public defenders.
"We, the jury,
find the defendant sexy."
Second, it's not true.
There isn't "one law and order."
We know that because anyone
who did even a fraction
of what you have done
would be in jail by now,
never mind the serial tax fraud
or profiting
from your public office
or the 10 allegations
of obstruction of justice
in the Mueller report.
Prosecutors have already
named you in an indictment
as the guy who orchestrated
a criminal scheme
to pay hush money during an
election to cover up an affair.
We have the check
with your signature on it.
You literally signed
the evidence.
Even O.J. knew better
than to make it clear
the Ford Bronco was his.
There isn't one law and order.
There are two separate
and distinct systems.
One is a system where the law
serves people of privilege,
and order preserves
their privilege,
where the police work for them.
And the other is a racist system
of predatory policing
that systematically devalues
black lives
and which acts as an occupying
force in their own communities.
And now we're seeing that system
unleashed on mass demonstrations
across the country,
with one video after another
making the rounds
of police descending
on peaceful protesters
and subjecting them
to brutal violence,
including here in new York.
-Last night in New York City,
there was both a curfew
and also a large
peaceful protest
that was happening
after the curfew.
The peaceful protest
then descended into violence,
not because of the protesters,
but because the NYPD
started beating people.
This is what that moment
looked like.
This is footage shot
in Manhattan last night.
It appears to show NYPD officers
just striking
a person on a bicycle
as onlookers recorded the scene
while stuck in traffic.
They are aghast, by the way.
And then other officers joined.
So there's four people beating
this one guy on his bike?
Videos have been appearing
on Twitter from protests
in New York City
of the past week,
showing police using batons
on protesters.
-What the [bleep] is going on?!
Four cops beating a guy
walking away with his bike?
That's never called for.
Even if he's one of those bikers
who overuses his bell,
the most -- the absolutely most
they deserve is a middle finger.
These aren't just
some isolated scuffles.
We're seeing it
across the country.
They're trying
to send a message.
That's why they're raining
tear gas
and flashbangs and pepper spray
down on everyone
from protesters to reporters.
Like this cop just casually
launching pepper balls
at a reporter who's reporting
it live on the local news.
Think of how shameless
you have to be
to do that on live television.
What's that cop
going to do next?
Live-stream himself
knocking over a liquor store
or parking
in a handicapped spot?
Police are lashing out
aggressively
because they see
that the protests are working
and that there's a growing
demand for police accountability
and for police resources
to be shifted elsewhere.
The mass demonstrations
have had a powerful impact
on public opinion.
A new poll found that Americans
support the protests
sparked by the death of George
Floyd by a nearly 2-to-1 margin.
By a 27-percentage-point margin,
Americans agree that blacks
and other minorities
are not treated equally
with whites
by the criminal justice system.
And that is huge. Huge.
I mean, you have to remember
millions of people --
most of them
over the age of 90 --
see this [bleep] every night.
-Big companies, cynical,
soulless, craven corporations
like Pepsi, Intel, and Airbnb,
are funding this chaos.
They're giving money
to Black Lives Matter,
which is pushing
to defund the police.
But it isn't just
major corporations
that are fueling all of this.
Celebrities are, too,
by paying to get
violent rioters out of jail.
As you read through this --
we're going to scroll
through their names
on the right side of the screen.
First off, actor Steve Carell
from "The Office"
donated to
the Minnesota Freedom Fund,
which is providing bail
to rioters.
Seth Rogen, Don Cheadle,
Janelle Monáe donated, as well.
The cast of
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
a police comedy, gave 100 grand
to help bail out people
who may very well have attacked
those they portray on TV.
Hollywood power couple
Blake Lively and Ryan Reynolds
donated $200,000
to the NAACP Legal Defense Fund.
-Wow, Tucker! You got 'em.
Steve Carell's career
will never be the same
now that you included him
in your little
fifth-grade
PowerPoint presentation.
I'm surprised you didn't
throw in some '90s clip art
like a globe or a cat.
Seriously,
why are your graphics so bad?
This looks like a 12-year-old's
Geocities website.
Couldn't even spell
Chrissy Teigen's name right.
I mean, I'm doing my show
from the attic,
but we can still pull together
a halfway
decent-looking graphic.
For example,
here is Tucker Carlson
with his pants around his ankles
being carried away
by a huge bird.
Ah! Nope. Never mind.
We also have a typo.
I take it back. [Bleep] Tucker.
This stuff is, uh, hard.
It's hard to do.
The privileged and the powerful,
the people served by a racist
system of predatory policing,
see that the public
overwhelmingly supports
the protests, and that's why
they're lashing out.
In recent days, the protests
have only continued to swell,
with massive peaceful crowds
streaming into cities
across the country.
If lawmakers can learn anything
from these crowds,
it's that mild reforms
won't cut it.
As we've seen, police will abuse
their authority
under any circumstances.
It's a fundamentally
corrupt system.
That's why you're hearing
protesters embrace the refrain
to defund the police.
We need to shift the money
we're spending on tanks
and tear gas and batons and
move it to community programs
like housing assistance
and health care.
It's not hard to do the math.
Just put someone in charge
who's...
-Always done well with numbers.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As New York struggles
to reopen this week,
remember that we are still
a city in crisis,
and City Harvest
has been stepping up
to meet the increased need.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.